so in which way would you say humans are
unique
versus
even our closest uh ancestors like is
there something special about humans
what is in your view under the pan
psychism i guess we're walking backwards
because we'll we'll have the big picture
conversation about what is pan psychism
but given
your kind of broad theory of
consciousness
what's unique about humans do you think
as a pan psychist
there is a great continuity between
humans and the rest of the universe
there's nothing
that special about human consciousness
it's just a highly evolved form of what
exists throughout the universe
so so we're very much continuous with
the rest of the physical universe
what is unique about human beings i
suppose
the capacity to
reflect on our conscious experience um
plan for the future
um
the capacity i would say to respond to
reasons
as well um i mean animals in some sense
have motivations
but when a human being makes a decision
they're responding to
what philosophers call normative
considerations you know if you're saying
should i take this job in the u.s you
weigh it up you say well you know i'll
get more money i'll have maybe a better
quality of life but if i stay in the uk
i'll be closer to family and you weigh
up these considerations
i'm not sure
any non-human animals
quite respond to considerations of value
in that way i mean i might be reflecting
here that i'm something of an
objectivist about value i think there
are
objective facts about what we have
reason to do and what we have reason to
believe and humans have access to those
and humans have access to them and can
respond to them that's a controversial
claim you know um
many of my panzerkiss brethren might not
uh
they would say the hamster too
can look up to the stars and ponder
theoretical physics maybe not but i
think it depends what you think about
value if you have a more
humane picture of value by which i mean
relating to the philosopher david hume
who said
reason is the slave of the passions
really we just have motivations
and what we have reason to do
arises from our motivations i'm not a
humane i think there are objective facts
about what we have a reason to do
and i think we have access to them i
don't think any non-human animal
has access to
objective facts about what they have
reason to do what they have reason to
believe they don't weigh up evidence i
don't think at the end of a hamster's
life it's it thinks did i ride the
roller coaster did i really live life to
the full that is not a mode of
reflection that's
available to non-human animals
you